there's a statuary standoff unfolding
between the state of wisconsin
and a branch of the u.s military more
than 30 years this statue of a badger
has been on display in the state capitol
in madison
problem is it's property of the united
states navy and it wants the badger back
to be displayed at the uss wisconsin
in norfolk virginia cbs news
congressional correspondent chris van
cleed takes us
inside this badger battle
the uss wisconsin is no stranger to
strife
her nine massive 16-inch guns pounded
japan during world war
ii and the battleship sailed into the
fight during the first gulf war
but now she finds herself in a battle
over a badger-sized piece of history
that's pitting this gray lady against
the wisconsin state house
it did not surprise me at all that this
has become quite
quite a thing of contention and that
people are pretty upset about it
the it historian erica janet is talking
about is this statue
of a badger that features the state
motto forward
it belongs to the navy but since 1988
the statue has sat
outside the wisconsin governor's office
in the state capitol where visitors rub
its nose
for luck there are generations of people
who remember
going to the capitol touching the
badgers nose
they just have this connection to it and
so it wasn't surprising at all that
the state doesn't really want to give it
back badgers are a big deal in wisconsin
in the state's early days miners digging
in the ground were compared to badgers
it became the state animal the namesake
of the university of wisconsin football
team and its mascot
bucky the badger the badger was part of
the original uss wisconsin but that ship
was scrapped after world war one
this is the new uss wisconsin built
during world war ii
the very last battleship the u.s navy
ever built
and it could be the badgers next home
the statue was crafted by a milwaukee
sculptor more than a century ago from
melted down cannonballs taken from cuba
during the spanish-american war
when the world war one era wisconsin was
scrapped the badger moved to the naval
academy before
being loaned to the state of wisconsin
for a temporary exhibit
three decades later wisconsin lawmakers
are in rare bipartisan agreement on
where this badger
should borrow it's state capital in
madison without question
in wisconsin were you surprised by the
the outcry in wisconsin
a little bit yeah a little bit
but i totally understand it this is a
source of pride
for the badger state stephen kirkland
runs the nauticus museum in norfolk
virginia
home to the uss wisconsin now a floating
exhibit that hosts more than 370
thousand visitors a year
we want to use the statue not just to
tell the story of
of the badger and the statue and the
history behind it
but tell this the story of this
battleship
and its heritage and its namesake and
the state it's named for the navy
approved the museum's application to
exhibit the statue
they plan to display it prominently here
in the wardroom a key stopping point for
tours
but at the urging of wisconsin's
congressional delegation the naval
academy museum
extended the loan to the state for two
more years i can't imagine
where it would get more use if you don't
have bucky badger as your mascot
i don't know if it would be as popular
in any other place in the country
every year i want the packers to win the
super bowl yeah of course i'd love for
the statues to say permanently
but the navy says they don't do forever
loans so this badger is likely heading
to the floating wisconsin
sooner or later would you be open to a
shared custody agreement
done here and a den in wisconsin
absolutely absolutely we want to do this
prudently
and um with the greatest of respect you
know
the old adage don't poke the bear no one
ever told us don't poke the badger
for now a stalemate in the badger battle
of the two wisconsins for cbs this
morning saturday
chris van cleave norfolk why can't you
just build an exact replica
not the same if you're in they both have
well i guess it's tough to find melted
cannonballs
these days it seemed like an awfully
heavy thing to put on a battleship i
don't know
it's cool it is cool